dude how funny would be if some kid like
that went up to you and goes hey what
are you doing out of your camp
[Laughter]
I thought I'd pushed I put away
[Music]
there's this boy right his name is uh
James lenninger I'm gonna say that's how
you pronounce it the authority on that
right here she's been a fan of planes
since he was two years old okay
as he's growing up one day he wakes up
screaming in the middle of the night oh
bro I'm about to ruin this article bro
you know this dude yeah I do no well I
don't know this specific I think I know
what it is no no ruin the video ruin the
video can I why would you want to do
this is your own [ __ ] Channel why
would you ruin videos here all right
tell me tell me tell me
Ryan you want me to you want me to act
it out all right I'm gonna act it out
yeah yeah act it out Mommy
um there's a plane
is that what we're doing now we're doing
that's what you read
so he wakes up screaming
and then what happens next I'm gonna
crash
he has PTSD
for the plane you know we if we're gonna
need to rehearse this before the [ __ ]
camera start rolling otherwise I don't
know how to pick up where you're leaving
up like where you're in like half of
this stuff
I'm like we're like farther in the story
all right sorry sorry I won't sound like
you're welcome in the middle of the
night plane okay okay okay okay let's
let's start imagine that you don't know
what happened what happened what
happened what happened what happened
what happened what happened
the young boy said he was on a plane
I'm playing the other
down by another aircraft bearing the
symbol of a red sun which James parents
interpreted as a Japanese yeah that's
what I was thinking too mommy then
Jeff's got me Mommy
I can say it because I'm Japanese yeah
okay so there was this there was a
speculation uh as crazy as it sounds
that that his parents thought that their
son had been reincarnated right after he
started speaking about memories of being
someone named James McCready Huston
do their parents do when you have kids
you should be doing that with drugs
anymore yeah dude
here's the thing though as it turns
transistin was a World War II fighter
pilot from Pennsylvania and died more
than 50 years ago in Japan
whoa his cause of death being knocked
out of the sky by a Japanese aircraft
wow so he had nightmares he had to get a
nightmare about this right so James
mother Andrea said her son would also
scream
[Laughter]
almost his son would also scream
airplane crash on fire can't get out
help during his sleep
James also told his parents that he'd
flown an aircraft called the Corsair
having set off from a boat named Natoma
during World War II yeah how old is this
kid this kid he started when he was like
two but then as he started growing up he
was still just having these when he was
two this started out he had a
fascination with planes and then started
like talking about this stuff right
after carrying out some research they
discovered that Huston
had actually been on a plane called
Natoma Bay when it was hit on March 3rd
1945. what the [ __ ] James's dad Bruce
said that as part of their research he
and Andrea wrote a letter to Huston's
sister Anne Barron explaining what their
son was going through and baron ended up
believing that James also was
Reincarnation of her older brother
saying the child was so convincing and
coming up with all the things that there
is no way in the world he could have
known wow wow that's pretty crazy
where is it where is it here's a photo
here's a photo of like when you were
saying all this in my head I'm like dude
the parents in on it I was trying to
find any way this is Jason
from Pennsylvania who died 50 years
earlier in World War II in Japan
literally a dude that exists explained
exactly as the kid had in his memories
psychologist Jim Tucker said that
Hudson's plane crashed in the exact same
manner that young James had described
both named James that's also very
slightly interesting James Hudson's
plane crashed exactly the way the James
lenger had described hit in the engine
exploding to fire crash into the water
and quickly sinking
and then what happened and when that
happened the pilot of the plane next to
his was Jack Larson when asked whether
James story could have been a figment of
his imagination Tucker replied if we had
never been able to verify that what the
child said matched somebody who died
then you could certainly just mark it
down as being fantasy but in cases like
James the previous person James Huston
was so obscure I mean he was a pilot who
was killed 50 years before and he was
from Pennsylvania and James was in
Louisiana I mean it seems absolutely
impossible that he could have somehow
gained this information as a
two-year-old through some sort of normal
means yeah
but how would you as a parent like hey
tell me that story again let me research
yeah yeah
how what would you do well I think that
the tough part is when they meet the
actual sister
and if he's able to ask questions like
what's your favorite food and he's like
check my mouth
that he's able to like say things like
that and his sister blows the sisters
yeah like wow only my brother would know
this I never got to say goodbye dude
that would like oh
did they meet up
um they they wrote a letter to the
sister and I'm guessing they either met
up or had some sort of conversations in
order to like verify some things because
uh the kid James was explaining [ __ ] to
the sister and the sister was like how
would you know those details but he
didn't know that was his sister so how
much does he know uh-huh he didn't look
at her to be like hey sis
yeah I don't think the article wrote
that he said hey sis yeah because you
know there's a lot of reincarnation
stories like this where like they would
see the family members and then they'll
just be like oh that's my sister
or like crazy [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] anybody
here believe in reincarnation
I kind of do a little bit Yeah but I
want to see some real [ __ ] like this kid
he sees like minorities and he no only
knows how to call them biracial slurs
yeah and then they're like wait a second
he was like I'm sorry it's just from my
time that's the names of you guys yeah
he calls a Japanese man a [ __ ] check your
face yeah that's a nerdy jab he only
knows
yeah yeah there's no bad stuff come on
I'm surprised they didn't turn this into
a movie like Dragon this actually wasn't
a Netflix documentary wow
James is one of the subjects of Netflix
documentary surviving death
it's kind of funny because you really
would believe if a guy like that was
reincarnated into a kid he'd probably be
on the grittier side of [ __ ] seeing as
the maximum racist someone could ever be
is when they're fighting that race in a
war that's true in Japan in their
country so 90 of your dialogue should be
slurs that one should have woke up and
then Mommy those dirty jobs Got Me by me
and she's like what I've never eating
sushi again mom maybe they just left
that out of the documentary because like
we can't just call people Jabs
the kid can't wrap his head around it
he's like why'd you edit me yeah I
didn't say that they just keep bleeping
it's not what James Hudson said yeah
shut the [ __ ] up you're too imagine like
a little girl rolling up you said I'm
your grand like I was your grandma
see if somebody rolled out to me as I I
was your former Grandma I'd be like oh
that's crazy but if they started saying
[ __ ] proper nouns like actual names
and [ __ ] like the way that that's a
trip something like that that would [ __ ]
me up like let me call Netflix really
quick get a check and then we can tell
me the rest of the story like imagine
this kid's just like oh my name was
James blah blah husband uh I was on the
Natoma Corsair blah and just starting
throwing that pronouns out and [ __ ] you
know what I mean I'd be like dude how
funny would be if some kid like that
went up to you and goes hey what are you
doing out of your Camp
I thought I'd put you away shouldn't you
be at the San Diego race track
what would you say to this kid I'll be
like what the kid goes up to you did we
lose the war why are they everywhere and
he's like oh maybe that's what that kid
at the projects was you ching ching
chong
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] welcome back sir thank you for
your service
here's a purple heart
I do believe in real coordination
because sometimes I feel like yo this
dude it's it's his first round being a
human being I I I'm so convinced that
you were a pigeon in your past life
because you don't know how to be a human
and you are kind of like pretty much an
animal but he thinks you made it to a
human that means you were a good pigeon
yeah like you would go up the ranks
right I think you start as a butterfly
or you know a worm butterfly chimpanzee
you did right yeah pigeon human so this
guy was a good fighter pilot that's why
he got reincarnated into a two-year-old
maybe that's all you got to do is put
him in a room I grew up in a Buddhist
family too so um whatever my small Mikey
grasp at the time as a kid with
reincarnation I was like oh [ __ ] dude if
I [ __ ] [ __ ] up I'm gonna come back as
a grasshopper or some [ __ ] somebody's
gonna step on me right and for some
reason I was convinced that I wasn't
going to do well enough to come back as
a human so I was just like hoping for at
least like maybe like a dog or something
like that you know what I mean I would
love to be a Pomeranian yeah I'd love to
be a pet where our family could still
take me in to treat me good but my back
has a dog that's good yeah that's a good
life bro being a dog I mean yeah Michael
big dogs oh yeah people imagine coming
back is like a tree
I mean that's nice but you're like also
like like this is it no but you get to
go like you get to stretch but imagine
like people walking up pissing on you or
the dogs yeah I'd be flattered a [ __ ]
bird just picks it through your [ __ ]
body and makes a nest in your sh you're
like yo dog come on man you're not gonna
die so like you have to wait a long time
you read cardio yeah until somebody
[ __ ] flicks a cigarette in your area
oh yeah and then someone Burns you
[Music]
and then you come back as another tree
and like [ __ ] I gotta grow again dude
it's hard to mess up as a tree though
that's probably why uh to come back in
history you can't really [ __ ] up right
you didn't put enough shade out there
the best test for this kid to see if if
he's legit should put him in a room full
of Japanese people like what do you feel
right now he's sweating anger he pauses
[Applause]
I don't know what came over me
so have you seen the documentary yet I'm
not have you seen the documentary I
don't watch dumb [ __ ] like that so hey
what do you think do you think this is
[ __ ] all right am I skepticism in me
I think I I don't think he named any
names I think he just woke up named the
plane and all this [ __ ] and his dad
[ __ ] filled in oh that's just what I
think yeah one of the theories is like
that's what I think too when the parents
got like they were just like man what is
this they they went to the library and
then they got all these like World War
II books and things and they started
like looking at stuff and the kids were
pointing out that was the plane I was in
or whatever yeah so then they're like
it's a lot of the Skeptics that are like
they saw the story they're like well
yeah you fed them the [ __ ]
information that's what I gave them all
these books when you're curious and then
he memorized the [ __ ] planes and then
he picked up the racism for Japanese
people afterwards after that because
there's no there's never gonna be any
proof that he said all those names yeah
there's only proof that he did say he
woke up in lie detector tests lie
detector test
[Music]
foreign